jason okay
well on that fun note please give it up
for your next comic but also one of my
favorite comics in austin the very funny
and talented mr holland's
[Applause]
kids you guys
it's gonna be here
i know what it look like but i'm not
that into anime
[Music]
that guy's really into anime
that's what kept them
saying through high school
i'm not that into anime which is
unfortunate because the only women who
are sexually attracted to me they're
pretty into
i forgot i have resting anime face
i'm on days like oh very interesting
where did you grow up
and then a [ __ ] anime date
which is where you pass out holding
hands
[Music]
no one likes that
um i'm uh
tired of women call me calling me a
premature ejaculator
signature to who
i came right at the perfect time
but i felt amazing
thanks maturity and now to yourself lady
my friends are like dude need to learn
how to talk to women
maybe or maybe women should learn how to
listen to hans
why i don't want to hear about the
federal reserve
or at a party
uh but i do want the ladies i don't
think i'm gonna [ __ ] a dude sorry fellas
i've never looked at a beautiful woman
and they're like wow is there a version
of her that's bigger and hairier and
there's less kindness
i want to stick that on my butthole
please believe me my dad doesn't
my lovely why would you want to be gay
if you're gay that means most of the
gender you're attracted to isn't even
attracted to you back
i was like whoa i can't even imagine
what that would be like
trying to do it
too bad
glad they're not killing themselves
right now
a lot of people will be like adam and
eve not adam and steve but adam and eve
were not even a good couple biblically
first of all i don't even disobey god
and ate a fruit they weren't supposed to
eat which is kind of gay
i gotta have a fruit let's get as [ __ ]
and then uh adam lee raised kane who
murdered abel why are we taking your
parenting advice and people raised a
serial killer
he killed a quarter of the world's
population
you're a startup yeah you shipped
together
you just killed half the genetic
diversity on earth
forget about purple mexicans
can you imagine the possibilities
but uh i'm an atheist now because i'm
not a kindergarten i have an internet
connection
i think it'd be stressful to have an
ideology that can be destroyed by facts
they're like walking down the street oh
look apostle [ __ ]
i guess i could have been blowing jesus
this whole time
only i'd seen that fossil earlier
but
my sister just got back from a mission
trip
if you don't know that that's where
americans go to their world countries to
get new profile pictures
she was like did you know that your
toilet water is cleaner than the
drinking water in africa
i was like what do you want me to do
about it these are the pipes that we
have they just pack the [ __ ] in fresh
if i see an african walking down the
street i don't drink from my toilet it's
not a problem
just flush afterwards i don't want to
get aids
but uh i am asian or as i'm around this
country i'm chinese
i'm from a province in china called
south korea
it's right next to japan province
i love being asian because whenever
someone is racist to me i'm just like oh
you hate respectful people who keep to
themselves
okay
they love finding an affordable car
i'm trying really hard
um a lot of people think asian women are
beautiful not everybody's asian men are
beautiful which doesn't even make any
sense because any asian women are
created
being [ __ ]
i'm a crucial part of the sexy process
please stop trying to skip me
if you have sex with me our children
will be very beautiful
half of them
the other half will be great engineers
and that's important
um white women are intimidated today
asian men because we're better being
women than they are
we're better getting interrupted we're
better being less intimidating in a
fight and we're better at being told
what to do all three things women should
be good at and unfortunately we're
better at it than you and also i don't
have to shave as much
and
my waist is thinner than yours
a very small man
uh but it was good to be here weighing
140 pounds in front of you guys um
i i'm not a big fan of asian women
because they act like they're hotter
than asian men but we look exactly the
same [ __ ]
i could throw on a wing at ps7
why are you always bragging that you can
[ __ ] white dudes i can [ __ ] white dudes
they all
the perverts
i love the whites very strong military
oh my god gotta respect the military
or else they'll [ __ ] sell opium in
your harbors
okay awards
uh love the whites uh i think of a white
pride is a good thing but a lot of
people do it correctly they're always
looking like the nazis and the
confederate flag they're never into
building a castle or yelling
that's not why pride that's racism
you don't have to be white to hate the
jews i can do that too
i know but i could
uh being an um
and also how to grow up in the christian
religion because the people who are in
the bible they didn't seem to know that
asians existed
they shouldn't even drop us a line
hey asians rachel are inventing the
fireworks and the compass and the great
wall china
anyways back to the jews my favorites
oh [ __ ] things about the goddamn jews
we're great people
it's just annoying
but i love the jews
really great banks
and
the media they're controlling it
um
i'm not a racist i'm a minority how
could i be impossible
i don't even see right now they smell it
especially the browns
i was
yeah it's not true it's just a joke
brown people smell the same as every
other race
i i love uh living in america i saw a
dude on an airplane reading a book in
arabic which kind of freaked me out but
then i thought i'd pull the corner of
the page to put the book away and i was
like oh thank god he's got these plans
he's gonna kill us all
but he has a book to finish um i
i love uh delivering ubereats in my
college sweatshirt that way people can
see that the system isn't working
sometimes when i'm sad about how much
money i don't have i go to a building
with a revolving door and i make rich
people spin me around
i pay for this remember the bailout uh
but
i i believe in universal basic income i
think if everyone got one thousand
dollars every month you guys would be a
lot more bearable to be around
here's some money stop yelling on the
bus
i think poor people are disgusting
i want to get rid of them by giving them
a lot of money
so genocide we can all get behind
like only ceos were like how am i
supposed to motivate my employees if i
can't learn to threaten that with a
homelessness at that
uh but i love capitalism i think
capitalism is great if you want to do it
just coming everyone plays stupid game i
like fortnite i don't make your grandma
play or take away her house if she loses
i like how people will say communism
never works as if we did spend billions
of dollars and get millions of people to
make sure it doesn't
work remember nicaragua and chile and
costa rica and cuba and vietnam and the
congo
we're pretty anxious about it not
working we're like uh how many is it
never works because whenever people
control the means of production they're
democratically elected leaders
mysteriously die
and a small rebel group always finds
automatic weapons and look they're
hitting themselves
why are you destabilizing yourself
but uh yeah i believe in any
uh republican policies that they
consider communism whenever republicans
consider communism i support it which is
whenever two or more people gather to do
something nice
so i'm pretty uh revolutionary and stuff
uh but i think it's weird that uh people
say in america don't drop the soap
should be go pick up the soap
you can drop as much stuff as you want
is the bending over where they only get
you
even if you don't drop the stuff you're
still getting a raise you're just gonna
really clean hands
very much
give it up for heart
[Applause]